hello them thank you for clicking on
this video and my quest to bring you
videos of me talking about things I'm
interested in so let's talk about some
really dark twisted lore filled
Metroidvania crushing difficulty good
times
[Music]
blasphemous so blasphemous is a game out
for all the main console cs4 Xbox one
intend to switch PC developed by the
game kitchen published by team17 it's a
Metroidvania game which I hopped onto
this because I just finished playing
Castlevania Symphony of the Night and
Rondo of blood but I didn't do a video
on that what can I say about Castlevania
Symphony of the Night that hasn't
already been said about Symphony of the
Night it's wonderful it's amazing it's
fantastic its godlike its perfection
married if I could Rondo of blood I feel
like I could probably talk about it's
not a lot of people talk about Rondo of
blood but he's both a great I wanted
another Metroidvania game I stopped
blasphemous on the PlayStation Network I
was like oh that was on my radar for a
hot second and I just got on two other
things so I got it and I played it
compared to Symphony of the Night
it's mm much harder it takes place in
this really religiously dark and
fucked-up world there's this curse
that's come over the land called the
miracle so you play as someone called
the penitent one and you hack and slash
your way through this game to the end
well concealed hack and slash if they
let you hack its lives if you just try
to hack and slash your way through this
your [ __ ] you adapt to survive you block
dodge then hack block dodge again hack
again and then keep bringing it up
because if I just say oh it's a
Metroidvania game II but look I places
in video tonight let's do it but this
games actually compared more to side
scroller Dark Souls
it is a punishing game if you die the
game lets you know it because of save
points it's not like they're in every
other room sometimes there are ways away
so when you die you missed that jump or
you make the jump and then you get hits
like yeah but God [ __ ] you have to trek
through that area that killed you to get
your spirit so you can get rid of your
guilt it's not a cakewalk sometimes like
when I play games like this I'm always
like [ __ ] kite you know is it worth
it is it worth it like why do people
play in this [ __ ] and then you get past
the zone or beat the enemy that's really
beating your ass you're like that's
right and that's the point of it you
know that feeling of yeah that's why you
don't come at me you do have relics that
you can equip you have rosary beads that
you can equip that give you stat buffs
and you find more rosary beads slot so
you can equip more of them you have
abilities you unlock that you purchase
from currency you get from killing
enemies you find prayers that are
essentially spells you get to equip one
of those at any given time so you must
choose
the true spies today but you never get
different weapons you know your sword is
always the same not like you get a sword
that completely plays differently than
another sword which I get though cuz you
can't just get the Chrissa grim or crisp
a grim however you want to pronounce it
from Symphony of the Night game breaking
sword you can't just get a sword like
that in a game like this that would
change the entire dynamic of the game
it's not about a sword that hits
differently it's about you adapting to
enemies and taking them on differently
in different kinds of enemies in the
room and looking around going okay of
sizing up that situation well why when
you start getting it down you feel
pretty boss and it's not just the save
points that feel sparse in this game
it's also the fast travel for a while I
was like where is the fast travel and
then you get it you get a little bit of
fast travel but there's only a few spots
of fast travel but really this is where
I'm praising the game of the most it's
the tone it's the atmosphere
it's the lore it's the world that is
glorious in this game the game itself is
fun but the art style and the lore
that's what sucked me in I love the
sprite based art because old games were
sprite based but now you can have more
frames of animation and say Super
Nintendo Cotto this makes the game feel
amazing that's why Street Fighter 3
third strikes my favorite Street Fighter
game one of my top two if not no no it's
probably one does the frames of
animation per character just glorious
when I was playing this game there was
something that took me back to the first
time I played blood um and legacy of
kain you look at the legacy of kain
games the gameplay itself it's nothing
enormous ly special but it's the lore
among this world that makes it feel
lived in and real just had that same
feeling playing this that I had the
first time I played blood home and
legacy of kain though the two play very
differently
hello DOMA legacy gains an overhead game
they're different games but there's
something about that lore in fact the
way I described blasphemous to a couple
of people was it's like The Avenues
Cathedral and blood home and legacy of
kain but the whole game I appreciate a
game like this especially one that's
just so heavily grounded in religion the
whole game is about this really messed
up religious world every item you find
every trinket it has a backstory it has
lore attached to it and read it it's
just it makes it feel more real it's not
just like a thing that could have gone
for some voiceover for all the items
like blood um and legacy it can have but
it's fine that the lore is still there
and in terms of the art style yes some
of it just sticks with
which is really twisted [ __ ]
[Music]
that's the thing of nightmares my jaw
hit the floor there's a one-hit kill he
does where the baby just takes you and
rips you in half like a piece of tissue
paper I was like yeah the guy sticks
with it which actually brings me to the
music
the music's amazing as well found out
there was actually a vinyl soundtrack
that's sold out damn it but I will say
the map and blasphemous is terrible in
terms of end game cleanup you know you
beat the game you want to find all the
extras and farm your trophies the map
there were quite a few occasions where
you look at the map you're like I don't
know where I can go it turns out you
have to go to this room that you haven't
been in but the map makes it look like
you have been in that room already would
have appreciated if the map say had the
outline of the room but it was dark so I
knew the room existed but I haven't been
there yet an invisible room entirely
that secret I totally get the map
shouldn't be showing that but to have a
room that's lit up as if I've been there
and what am I supposed to memorize the
entire map the [ __ ] out of here I'm not
memorizing all that [ __ ] so that was
kind of irritating also there are
miserable trophies which trophies
they're not necessary but I always do
appreciate it when I can get all the
trophies in one playthrough or a couple
of trophies where it's like you got that
you cannot get that a couple of times
trophies basically if I want to get the
trophies I have to start another game
but it's probably not gonna happen
anyway because beat all the bosses
without using a healing flask what what
come on what well probably not I don't
know sounds like it could be a fun
challenge anyhow blasphemous I had a
blast from this you clicked on my video
you only have yourself to blame
for hearing cheesy jokes it has fun yet
challenging sometimes crushing gameplay
but human beings are very adaptable you
will adapt to survive and by the end
you're just cooking through these
animations until you come across a new
one and he beats your balls in but hang
in there you'll get him the game could
use a bit of polish when it comes to the
map so I was gonna say it's worth buying
at full price before price is $24.99 it
just doesn't quite say enough plus I'm a
sucker for lore and tone and this game
is lore and tone atmosphere this game
just does it right plus I lived and
breathed this game for a week
like it's a part of me it's a part of my
dark twisted fucked-up soul or kindred
spirits is game and I so I gotta say
blasphemous is awesome tacular but the
devs are out there if they're watching
this so they're planning on it yeah but
please bring out a sequel I would be
happy I would love that
alright so blasphemous have you played
it what did you think about it or what's
your favorite Metroidvania game or
crushingly challenging game whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]